This is the one question an atheist cannot answer.
Let's play it. Um,
I don't know. That's a if that, um,
atheists and agnostics, uh,
once they, like,
choose that path or their point of view.
Um, do you believe that they can't be as moral as Christians?
Oh, no.
Christian atheists, agnostics can be just as moral as anybody else.
Um, the question isn't, can you.
Do you need god to be moral?
You have to believe in god to be moral.
No, there's atheists that are very moral.
Um, the.
The question is, can you justify morality without god?
And that's the problem, right?
It's not, can you act morally?
Course atheist can act morally.
The question is, can you justify what is moral without god?
And I say no. It's just your opinion. If there's no god for me,
I was raised in family with,
I would say not sound conceited,
but with very high morals.
Okay. Respect.
Yeah, good.
It's point of view.
I'm very open minded.
Good. Um,
so, uh,
how would that.
How would god influence me to be more moral?
Even if, like,
I think of myself
and people tell me that I'm a decent and moral person?
Well, let's back up for a second and ask the question,
what is the purpose of life?
Is the purpose of life to be moral?
Um,
I don't know. That's a
no. I wouldn't.
Well, that's.
I guess I would say no.
But what is The purpose, then,
um, to make the world a better place.
That would be.
Then be more. Why?
Well, yeah,
I guess. Yeah,
in a sense, it would be, um,
so that our children and grandchildren can leave.
Who cares? We're ultimately gonna burn out one day.
So what. What's the ultimate purpose?
So that we can live longer and humans can stay on the earth.
So what, ultimately, it's all gonna.
We're gonna spin out,
we're gonna. Gonna heat death.
Okay, so is there any ultimate purpose?
There may be short term purposes,
but no ultimate purpose.
Yeah, that's true.
Okay, so in the very long term.
Right. In the very long term,
there's no purpose.
So why even care about the short term, then?
Because I care about my children and grandchildren.
Right, but so did Stalin.
And that. Stalin lived a great life for himself
and his children and grandchildren
by killing everybody around them and taking their stuff.
Yeah, he's a bad person,
so. Yeah,
but what do you mean by bad?
He's killing other people.
Why is that wrong?
Because it's. It's.
I mean, it's not good to kill other people. Why not?
Because that's the.
I mean, that's what most people said.
Yeah, but who said Hitler said it was good to kill other people?
Stalin said it was good to kill her.
Why. Why is that?
Why are they wrong?
Because they, uh.
They killed millions of people.
I know, but why is Killing millions of people. Wrong.
If there's no god.
Because, um,
I, yeah,
I mean, I, I,
I would just say because it's ruining the human race. And it's right.
But it presupposes that there's some value to human beings, right?
Uh huh. It presupposes that god does not exist.
Objective moral values do not exist.
And here's why.
Without some objective reference point,
we have no way of saying that something is really up or down.
God's nature provides an objective reference point for moral values.
It's the standard against which all actions and decisions are measured.
But if there's no god,
there's no objective reference point.
All we are left with is one person's viewpoint,
which is no more valid than anyone else's viewpoint.
This kind of morality is subjective,
not objective.
It's like a preference for strawberry ice cream.
The preference is in the subject,
not the object.
So it doesn't apply to other people.
In the same way,
subjective morality applies only to the subject.
It's not valid or binding for anyone else.
So in a world without god,
there can be no evil and no good.
Nothing but blind,
pitiless indifference.
God has expressed his moral nature to us as commands.
These provide the basis for moral duties.
For example,
God's essential attribute of love is expressed in his command
to love your neighbour as yourself.
This command provides a foundation
upon which we can affirm the objective goodness, generosity,
self sacrifice and Equality.
For The atheist humans are just accidents of nature,
highly evolved animals.
But animals have no moral obligations to one another.
When a cat kills a mouse,
it hasn't done anything morally wrong.
The cat's just being a cat.
If god doesn't exist,
we should view human behaviour in the same way.
No action should be considered morally right or wrong.
But the problem is good and bad, right and wrong do exist.
Dresses our sense experience
convinces us that the physical world is objectively real.
Our moral experience
convinces us that moral values are objectively real.